wimbledon organizers say they won't back
down despite the prestigious tournament
being stripped of ranking points it
essentially turns the tournament into an
exhibition event
tennis governing bodies made the
decision after wimbledon banned
competitors from russia and belarus over
the ukraine war
in a statement wimbledon says we remain
unwilling to accept success or
participation at wimbledon being used to
benefit the propaganda machine of the
russian regime we therefore wish to
state our deep disappointment at the
decisions taken
by the atp the wta and the itf in
removing ranking points for the
championships
let's go to nadim baba in london nadeem
so talk us through all the reaction at
the all england lawn tennis club
well as you were just saying the
club the all england long tennis club
better known as wimbledon a standing
firm they've expressed deep
disappointment in the move by the atp
and wta tours not to give ranking points
for this
tournament uh in a statement they
repeated that the ban in their opinion
was the only option available to them
under uk government guidance to do with
the war in ukraine um they say that
they're in discussions with other grand
slam uh tournaments they're seeing what
can be done perhaps on an international
level
the statement that the club put out on
friday uh called the move
disproportionate in the context of the
exceptional and extreme circumstances
saying that it was damaging to all
players who compete on the tour well the
atp for its part has pushed back and
said that that's basically nonsense
saying that their move is protecting the
system and the players they say it's
with great reluctance that they've moved
removed ranking points from wimbledon
saying that unilateral decisions of the
nature such as um wimbledon's ban if
unaddressed set a damaging precedent for
the rest of the tour
so nadine how is this going to affect
the players
well i think there are various opinions
amongst the professional players we know
that um this um the ban rules out some
really high-profile players such as
russia's daniel medvedev the world
number two in the men's rankings and
also last year's semi-finalist here
belarusian uh uh arena sabalenka so
these are big names but not just that
we've already heard uh rafael nadal say
that he was against uh the ban the
outright ban on belarusian and russian
players
know that djokovic
of course the world number one
he is against the ban he said before the
latest move he wouldn't be speaking
until the announcement about the ranking
points so we're waiting to hear from him
possibly in the next day or so um
the move means that um djokovic himself
will lose his world number one status
because he won't be able to get the 2
000 points that he earned last year for
winning wimbledon uh he's currently 680
points ahead of medvedev medvedev
himself has said that there were a lot
of mistakes made
behind wimbledon's move to ban him and
his compatriots as well as players from
uh belarus a reminder that they are
allowed to play other tournaments such
as roland garros in paris just not under
the national flag so it's a very very
complicated situation but all sides
sticking to their guns for now
very interesting nadim no doubt this
story has more to come nadine baba there
in london for us